i'm not sure
pregnancy
i'm coming out
war
where are you from
well
are you getting out here
okay
did you bring the phone
um
you think i'm driving
thank you
oh
oh
departure
we have to go straight to the power
yes
now
right
trump
you know what happened
i would never qualify
don't get a tesla get in here
every time
where's
[Music]
sorry
is
right
[Music]
at this point
yeah 5060.
and then tether to your phone
anymore
um
um
um
[Music]
80 years
but
oh
um
that's
um
right
happy
okay
i don't have any farms
that was monday and he had something on
thursday
now
regulations
this is one of your pictures somebody
uh
which
oh
um
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats as the program will begin
momentarily
but they wanted
perfect
good vibes
yes
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Applause]
well thank you very much everybody
please
this promises to be a very big and very
important
meeting so uh bear with me
take a little while but it has to do
with a thing called drug pricing
and as you know congress has been
working on this for decades and decades
and
we are now doing something that is uh
going to be incredible for the american
public
so today i'm taking a bold and historic
very dramatic action to reduce the price
of prescription drugs
for american patients and american
seniors
previous administrations did nothing
absolutely nothing
as drug lobbyists special interests in
foreign countries fairly ripped off
our citizens under the last
administration alone drug prices rose a
staggering 55 percent
thanks to my administration's aggressive
actions since taking office
we have successfully lowered drug prices
for the first time in 51 years
but this reduction is still not close to
what i want
what i expect and i'm looking for
help for our great seniors especially in
particular and that's what we're doing
today you'll
hear something which will be very
shocking so we're doing things that
nobody thought
could be done it's going to have an
incredible impact unfortunately we've
been waiting for
congress to take action for many decades
to reduce drug prices for more than
uh more than just a small handful of
people
but even the small handful of people
never got
price reductions and i'm unwilling to
wait any longer
therefore today i'm signing four
sweeping executive orders that will lead
to
massive reduction in drug costs massive
we've already gotten them down a little
bit but that's not good enough
first time in 51 years as i said but
that's not good enough
they represent the most far-reaching
prescription drug reforms ever issued
by a president nothing even close
joining us
for this important occasion our
secretary of health and human services
alex where is alex alex thank you alex
azar
cms administrator both doing a great job
sema verma
seema thank you seema
fda administrator dr stephen hahn
stephen who's really speeding up the
process of therapeutics and vaccines and
i just heard from some of the
big drug companies and they're saying
fda has really been
moving the process along very important
stephen can you move it faster please
okay
thank you great job we appreciate it
and administrator of health resources
and service
administration tom engels tom thank you
thank you very much tom for being here
we're also pleased to have with us
our great governor from the state of
florida
incredible state incredible guy governor
ron desantis thank you ron
very much appreciate it and you're going
to say a few words in the end good
representative matt gates our friend
where is hi matt you're so quiet back
there today i've never seen you like
that
thank you matt great job you're doing
appreciate it very much
speaker of the florida house of
representatives jose
oliva jose thank you jose
very much good job and many other state
and local leaders have a lot of them
thank you very
much being here the four orders i'm
signing today will completely
restructure the prescription drug
market in terms of pricing and
everything else to make these
medications
affordable and accessible for all
americans
the first order will require federal
community health centers to pass the
giant discounts they receive
from drug companies on insulin and
epipens
directly to their patients you know
insulin became so expensive people
weren't able to use it they desperately
needed it
we have it to a level that you're not
going to believe epipens
likewise you've been reading horrible
stories about epipens over the last
six seven years horrible horrible
horrible increases
where they went from almost nothing to
massive amounts of money
we're changing that right now these
providers should not be
receiving discounts for themselves while
charging their poorest patients
massive full prices under this order the
price of insulin
for affected patients will come down to
just pennies a day pennies a day from
numbers that you weren't even able to
think about
it's a massive cost savings
the second executive order i'm signing
this afternoon will allow states
wholesalers and pharmacies to do
something other politicians have
promised
for decades and decades but never done
they never delivered we will finally
allow the safe and legal
importation of prescription drugs from
canada
and other countries where the price for
the
identical drug is incredibly lower it's
a difference like you wouldn't believe
70 percent 80 percent 90
30 but massively lower
than the identical drug made in the same
plant the same factory the same exact
drug same everything same box
same pill and yet it's 50
60 70 percent lower
and this is something that ron and i
have been discussing
from the time ron got elected and i've
been wanting to do
it and it takes a long time from a legal
standpoint
and we've got it all worked out
so you're going to be getting massive
drug savings in florida and other states
and we've had numerous states that
wanted to do it ron really was at the
forefront i will say that but
you have other states that have caught
on it's caught on very quickly
didn't take them long to figure that one
out ron it's too obvious we pay for all
of the research and all of the
development in foreign countries pay
absolutely nothing and our consumer gets
charged it's been going on for decades
the american people pay an average of
over three times more for medicine than
the canadians
many people go to canada i see it all
the time they go to canada buy drugs and
then they come back
prescription drugs because they save so
much money the trip is well worth it
the obama biden administration pledged
to end this unfairness and allow drug
importation but they never got it done
they were unable to get it done
they didn't get a lot of things done but
under my administration we're standing
up
to the lobbyists and special interests
and fighting back against a rigged
system wreak system you've heard that
word before
i'm unrigging the system that is many
decades old
we're doing something that should have
been done a long time ago
the third revolutionary order i'm
signing today will prevent
middle men and women i guess
but you've heard about the middleman
right the middleman that makes so much
money nobody knows who they are nobody
has any idea who they are they make more
money
perhaps than even the drug companies
themselves and the drug companies in all
fairness to them
big pharma and they're doing a great job
in the vaccines they're doing a great
job in therapeutics i can tell you
because i deal with them a lot
but i think that middlemen make more
money than they do they don't do much
maybe they don't do anything some people
say
they don't do anything nobody even knows
who they are
but the middlemen are making a fortune
and pharmacy benefit managers and
people are just bilking
medicare patients with these high drug
prices
while they pocket gigantic discounts
gigantic
discounts the amount of money they've
made over the decades is
too incredible even to
speculators say it's it's
massive some very rich people are not
going to like me very much today i can
tell you
i probably know them very well i
probably see them in palm beach
but nobody ever talks about who they are
everyone i hear the middlemen for years
the middlemen
right alex and he doesn't know who they
are either but he knows they're rich
they're not going to be so rich anymore
because the money is going down to
reduce the price of
drugs prescription drugs so
that's a big thing that's a tremendous
step
it should have been taken a long time
ago but they have a great deal of power
and i don't have to tell you how many
phone calls i've had in the last
few days when they heard i was going to
be doing this i've heard from people
that i haven't spoken to in a long time
frequently drug companies give these
middlemen discounts of up to 50 percent
on the price of prescription drugs
but too often those discounts are not
passed on to the
pharmacy counter meaning the people
this rule will pass those billions and
billions of dollars a year
i mean many many billions a year in
discounts onto patients directly onto
patients saving
americans with high drug costs thousands
of dollars a year individual people will
make thousands of dollars a year you're
not going to believe the impact that the
things we're talking about today
are are going to have mark meadows our
chief our great chief is sitting here
and he's just
can't even believe it because he was a
very successful congressman he's been
after people to do this for a long time
and they never got to the gate i
understand why
tremendous pressure tremendous pressure
put on the president
not to do it the fourth and final order
i'm signing today
is the granddaddy of them all will end
global freeloading on the backs of
american patients and american seniors
for decades our citizens have paid
the highest prices for drugs
prescription drugs
anywhere in the world and it's not even
close
foreign nations have paid vastly less
for the exact same drug again in the
exact same
box from the exact same plant
from the exact same company
they would pay ten percent twenty
percent 30 percent
what our people are paying a pill that
would sell for
for one dollar in certain countries i
won't name them they're all
allies right they call them allies i
call them so-called
allies but a pill that would cost a
dollar could be
seven eight dollars in our country same
exact pill
we pay 80 more than nations like germany
canada and others for some of the most
expensive medicines
identical in all respects this means
that americans are funding the enormous
cost of drug research
and development for the entire planet
we are bearing the entire cost of all of
this they're bearing
they say this is what we're going to pay
in some cases it's a socialist country
so we're paying to reduce drug prices in
a socialist country
how does that work how does that work
and these are things that should have
been done a long time ago
and even from our standpoint we would
have done it
more quickly but we have to go through
vast amounts of
waiting periods waiting times
and this is an incredible day this is
just a big day
this is a big day i've been waiting for
this day for a long time
we incredibly and foolishly bear the
full cost of all
research and development which is
massive in all fairness to the drug
companies can take 15 years to get
something approved billions and billions
of dollars for a simple drug
it also means that the u.s taxpayers are
effectively subsidizing the socialist
healthcare systems
of foreign welfare states and many other
countries
we will end that abuse and restore the
principles of
free enterprise but this doesn't even
have to do with free enterprise this has
to do with common sense and courage
to be honest and courage under this
transformative order
medicare will be required to purchase
drugs
at the same price as other countries pay
so we would pay for five times more for
a drug we now pay if somebody else pays
one dollar and we pay five dollars we're
paying one dollar now what's going to
happen
is their number will go up our number
will come very substantially down and
we'll all agree at two and a half or
two or whatever the final number is but
if some country is paying
wherever it may be in the world because
they had a better negotiator because
they had smarter people than we have
and that's what it's all about maybe
more honest people who knows
could be a lot of things going but we
have
we get now the lowest price anywhere in
the world
and no more will we have to suffer by
saying gee why is it so much
cheaper for the exact same drug in some
other country
we will determine what other medically
advanced nations pay
for the most expensive drugs
instead of paying the highest price
medicare will pay the lowest price and
so will
lots of other u.s buyers medicare is the
largest purchaser of drugs anywhere in
the world by far
medicare the largest purchaser of drugs
in the world and we're finally going to
use that incredible power to achieve a
fairer and lower price for everyone
everyone will get a fairer and much
lower price this is not talking about
one-half of a percent this is big stuff
under our
ridiculous system which has been broken
for decades
we aren't even allowed to negotiate the
price of drugs can you believe it i said
what are we going to negotiate
we're not allowed we're restricted by
congress
from negotiating the price of drugs can
you imagine
you say i want to get a better price i'm
sorry sir you're not allowed to do that
that's illegal
what kind of a system is that you think
the world looks at us and said
where the hell did these people come
from
but they treat us very nicely but it's
not it's going to
end okay i see you're you're a fan of
what we're saying
you must be a doctor are you a doctor
yeah doctors know the doctors know
you've known that for years we're not
allowed to negotiate
can you believe it we just have to take
whatever it is
i'm pleased to announce that as a result
of the orders i'm signing today
the heads of the major drug companies
have requested a meeting to discuss how
we can quickly and significantly lower
drug prices and
out-of-pocket expenses for americans
they want to do what's right look
they're going to do what's right look i
i think it's so important
what they're doing on therapeutics and
vaccines and we're going to see them on
tuesday we'll see if we can do something
here but
this could have been done a long time
ago
the drug company executives will be at
the white house on tuesday
and they have some ideas how to
significantly reduce drug prices we've
already given
them to you i don't know if they can
possibly do something to substitute for
what's called favored nations favored
nations that means
we get the lowest price anywhere in the
world whoever gets the best price
congratulations
thank you very much for being a good
negotiator because we now get the lowest
price too
should have been done a long time ago if
these talks are successful
we may not need to implement the fourth
executive order which is a very tough
order
for them very tough and i understand
that
and we have a lot of respect for
our great pharmaceutical companies drug
companies we have a lot of respect for
them
so we'll see what they have to say on
tuesday maybe they have an idea that's
good but it's got to be very substantial
they're actually in favor of the rebate
rule the rollback
because they say that's people getting
money that aren't even doing anything
for
and bigger money than they're getting i
believe if they are not
the order will be implemented if we
don't do a deal
or agree to something the order
number four favored nations
a big order they're all big all four are
very big by the way
very big but the fourth quarter we're
going to hold that
until august 24th hoping that the
pharmaceutical companies will come up
with something that will substantially
reduce drug
prices and the clock starts right now so
it's august 24th at 12 o'clock
after which the order on favored nations
will go into effect
and mark i'll hold you to it please 12
o'clock not 1201 right
in the meantime we're working very hard
on therapeutics and a vaccine
for the china virus which remains our
top priority and which are coming along
at record speed thank you very much dr
han been fantastic you really have been
fantastic
two vaccine candidates are entering the
final stage of clinical trials this
month
right two and several more vaccines will
enter final trials in the following
weeks
i did speak to one just recently they're
working on therapeutics as opposed to
vaccine
and frankly i'm that's the most exciting
to me we can walk into a hospital right
now and
get people better i like that even more
but the vaccine long term will be
will be great so we have them both going
they're both going rapidly and they're
both going very well and
i guess the early indications are uh
beyond we're
beyond happy right it's beyond happy
we're mass producing
all of the most promising candidates
already so that on day one uh that means
that we think we have
the answer otherwise we wouldn't be
making that bet it's big bet
so that in day one the day we get it
approved it will be available
immediately doctor is that correct so we
get it approved
now normally this process would take to
get up to where we are now three years
four years i've heard numbers like that
and we did it in literally a matter of
weeks
it's a really incredible thing one of
the other things i was talking about
drugs in the pipeline for getting drugs
approved and it does cost billions of
dollars and it would be 12 years 15
years
and under dr han and scott
before you work very hard scott gottlieb
uh we've got that down to a number
that's less than half
and we're going down further we have to
make sure it's safe
and right to try came out of this whole
thing where
where we have a drug that we think is
good matt gates helped with this and
getting it approved and and mark when he
was a congressman
but we had great help from certain
people but right to try is
incredible we have a drug that works but
it's got to go through this very
long and very detailed process for
purposes of safety and to make sure it's
good
if somebody's terminally ill very sick
person's not going to make it person
very sick
we pass legislation which they've been
trying to get for 42 years
it's called right to try where people
sign a document
that if it doesn't work out they're not
suing the drug company they're not suing
the insurance company and they're not
suing
our country and instead of traveling if
they have money they travel to asia and
they travel to europe they travel all
over the world
in the hopes of finding a cure they're
terminally ill if they have no money
sadly they go home with no hope and they
die
we have now a program right to try
finally happened after
i guess as long as you've been a doctor
long before you became a doctor right
they've been trying to get this
but we have a program where they can try
these
really promising medicines and
you have no idea how successful this has
already been it's incredible
and one of the things that really came
out of it was the biggest problem for
the drug companies they didn't want it
because they didn't want it in their
sample
because people that are that sick they
don't want in the sample
and so we've created a separate sample
so it doesn't
hurt them but one of the things that's
come out of it is
if it works what what is a better
testing formula than that somebody
that's terminally ill and all of a
sudden
makes it and we're having examples of
that it's been incredible it's been an
incredible program
i hope somebody's going to be able to
write a story about it because it's been
one of the things that we've i'm very
proud of it i love the name even right
to try they have the right to try a drug
that's not going to be available for two
years or three years they're terminally
ill
before you'd say well they're terminally
ill yeah but we don't want to give them
a drug that's going to hurt them well
they're going to be
they're going to die and they didn't
want to give them a drug because they
thought it might be dangerous
and perhaps in some cases it may be
dangerous but we are having tremendous
tremendous success with that program
proud of it
additionally my administration has
secured 90 percent of the world's supply
of the drug
rem de severe which is having great
impact
for the united states and research
continues daily on a lot of promising
treatments as i said
as we take these historic actions we're
joined today by americans who have
already benefited from the steps
my administration has already taken to
reduce the cost of health care
and prescription drugs we're going to
have a big health care bill that we're
going to be putting up very shortly
and it's uh going to be very complete
and uh today what we're doing on
prescription drugs and again we'll have
to see what happens on august 25th we'll
either do the favored nations or not
depending on
the drug companies but what we're
putting up in a very short period of
time
on health care will be incredible we
have another one coming on immigration
tremendous bill on immigration
and it will be uh i think something that
nobody
thought we would be able to get so uh
that'll be great paul madden is a
senior citizen who relies on insulin
every day
he was paying a a fortune everything to
get it paul
if you could i think paul's in the
audience and if you could please come up
and say a few words about your
experience thank you paul
so you can hear me that's better
mr president thank you so very much
for this time to share a few key points
supporting your leadership
work reducing the price of insulin
and other diabetes related medicines
used by 34
americans each day to live healthier
fuller lives
as you heard my name is paul madden i'm
a bostonian i have lived with insulin
dependent diabetes for 59 years
beginning medicare last year
i quickly realized that my ability to
afford
prescribed insulins that worked best for
my health
was no longer possible because of their
excessive
high price soaring costs have
impacted the quality of my life remember
that number 34 million people with
diabetes
it's it's impacted so much i even
started
to use a 30 year old insulin to survive
which does not do quite the same great
job
of balancing my diabetes your work sir
to ensure that insulin is affordable
under medicare
will help guarantee that i and millions
of seniors
who take insulin realize healthier
more productive independent happier
lives
thank you for continuing your commitment
to ensure affordability and access for
all who use insulin
for people with diabetes
and so that our children and
grandchildren
will directly benefit from our improved
health
thank you thank you very much
it's actually brought it from many many
many dollars
unaffordable by most people to pennies
literally pennies a month and
i want to thank sema you worked so hard
on that one siri could you just say
something about that
it was uh the price would you come up
just for a second seema verma and
uh just tell them about what we've done
with respect to
very badly needed insulin
[Applause]
well the senior savings model that we
developed under the president's
leadership
is going to reduce the cost of insulin
to 35 dollars a month for our seniors
and that represents a 66 percent savings
i can tell you the vice president and i
were traveling in pennsylvania we had a
gentleman that came up to us and he
showed us his insulin and he said you're
going to save me five thousand dollars a
year
so thank you president trump for your
leadership thank you very much
that's a tremendous that's a tremendous
difference
we're also joined by andrea eckles a
dental hygienist from brunswick maryland
andrea please come up and say a few
words thank you please
[Applause]
thank you mr president thank you very
much
my name is andrea eckles and i am a
dental hygienist in brunswick maryland
um i was widowed when my husband died in
a tragic auto
accident and my twin girls were four at
the time
he held our family health insurance
through his corporate job
and i suddenly found myself having to
work full time
and put my children in full-time daycare
watch my budget very closely
this was a number of years ago and at
that time
my only choice for healthcare
i work in a very small dental office and
so my only choice for health care at
that time was what i
call the unaffordable care act
and i was paying very high premiums and
co-pays
and way too much for prescription drugs
and interestingly i
you referenced the um epi pen
and um i had to purchase epipens and
inhalers and
it got to the point actually where i
couldn't even afford to
renew the epipen i think i still have a
probably 15 year old ebby ben at my
house
because it just they've got to be 700
dollars
um but in my case this led what did they
start at so it's 700 what did they say
um
the original epipen um i
feel like it was like a 20 copay way
back when i first got
it but then as the each year you know it
just kept going up up to
um but i um incidentally ended up
with all of these increases and co-pays
and everything over time
i ended up with a over 15 000 medical
debt
and um and i'm just a regular person i
don't have
some ridiculously you know major
illnesses or anything
but during your presidency uh president
trump
my premiums have decreased exponentially
um and my coverage has increased
my co-pays have just about disappeared
you know we're going way down
and um prescription drugs that i used to
budget for myself
are at 150 a month is now 15
a month and because of you i'm spending
hundreds of dollars less a month and
this type of savings makes a really big
difference for a single mother
such as myself so i just want to thank
you so much from the bottom of my heart
and for all that you do
and for all of your policies that are
helping all of us americans thank you
very much
thank you
it's really nice i appreciate it some
big difference that's not
a one percent or a two percent that's
big that's big
dollars and i want to thank you both
very much thank you very much
today's actions continue my
administration's relentless drive to
deliver
better health care at a lower cost i
signed an executive order to fight
kidney disease that was such a big thing
it was such a
beautiful important thing to do
with more transplants and better
treatment
people with kidney disease go through
hell they go through hell their life is
hell
and we've done a lot and we're very
proud of it we've
really seen some results that are
incredible
we dramatically expanded the telehealth
for all american patients and families
in telehealth
and this pandemic era
have been it's increased by
uh i would say thousands like a thousand
twenty percent incredible it's been uh
up at a level that nobody's ever
imagined and it actually is very good
it's been something that
has come out of uh out of the pandemic
one of the only good things that came
out of it frankly is people are
realizing how good that is it really
worked out
well we strongly defended
medicare and social security and will
always protect and we have been
protecting
will always will protect republicans
totally protect
pre-existing conditions very important
nothing's going to happen to your
pre-existing
protections we ended the gag clause
that prevented pharmaceuticals and
pharmacists from
telling patients how to buy less
expensive drugs
with a clause that if you went up to a
pharmacist
this is a correct statement to this it's
not even believable
you couldn't talk about price if
the man or woman behind the counter
started talking about price what happens
you take the license away
this is not even believable so think of
that we prevented
it prevented pharmacists from telling
patients how to buy less expensive drugs
we have a less expensive drug that's
just as good i can't talk about it
they can't even say that
i wonder why can you imagine these
things we approved a record number of
affordable low cost
generics we've increased generics more
than any administration by
many times and many of the generics i
would say
from what i'm hearing all of the
generics sometimes people want to see a
label
but they say they're just as good as the
others
except you pay a lot less money we've
increased them more than any
administration not even close and we
capped insulin costs that we just
discussed for many medicare
recipients and for a lot of other people
at just 35 dollars a month and it was
many times that as you've just heard
right to try i talked about so proud of
it nothing matters more to me than the
health
and well-being of the american people
there's nothing more important to me
with today's actions we're ending
decades of sellouts betrayals and broken
promises from washington you've had a
lot of
broken promises i would say exclusively
broken
you've had it it's been uniform broken
promises
we're putting patients over lobbyists
senior citizens before special interests
and we're putting america first i'm
putting america first when you look at
what we're doing with
favored nations on the basis that it
kicks in on august 25th we'll see
see what they have to offer but
when you think about it what are we
doing we're putting america first
when you hear other countries getting a
much better deal on drug prices
there are people that have told me this
is more important than health care we're
doing health care but this is more
important than anything the price of
drugs they were getting
slaughtered slaughtered by drug prices
so thank you very much i want to thank
you all for being here i'd like to
ask if i could alex to come up please
secretary azar to say a few words and
then i'll sign an executive order i'd
also like to ask the governor of florida
ron you're going to come up and say a
few words and we'll sign up and you'll
go out and
buy those drugs and save 50 or 60
percent for the people of florida
and other people will be joining you and
that's great i want to let you
you will tell me how you do and i'd work
on it really fast because now with all
of the
media back here you're under
extraordinary pressure and you never
have pressure
one thing i'll tell you about ron matt
will tell you he handles pressure well
you're doing a great job thank you very
much please alex
well mr mr president uh thank you so
much for your leadership here
you charged all of us with four goals
ending foreign free riding improving how
our federal programs pay for drugs
lowering out of pockets for our citizens
and getting list prices down and you did
your
drug pricing blueprint in may of 2018.
before then
every single year there were massive
drug price increases
massive price inflation since your drug
pricing blueprint
those that level of inflation has
stopped
and that was an incredible
accomplishment but you said that's not
good enough
i want more even more change for the
american people and today
you're delivering the the import
allowing importation
presidents before you have promised over
and over again to allow
importa the safe importation of drugs
from lower-cost countries
you're the first president to deliver on
it you're going to have governor
desantis's program for states and tribes
to import
you're going to have a personal
importation program where individuals
can get their drugs low cost from abroad
and you're going to have an insulin
re-importation program so americans can
get their insulin re-imported from
canada at lower prices
you're taking on the the federal health
centers you're taking on the issue that
they are getting radical discounts on
insulin and epipens and you're going to
make sure low-income americans get the
benefit of those discounts
and you're taking on the middlemen 30
billion
a year of concealed kickbacks to
middlemen
are going to now flow to medicare
patients when they show up at the
pharmacy an average of 30
discounts and out of pockets when they
show up at a pharmacy thanks to the
president's
bold action and we're going to end
foreign free riding
taking on foreign socialist systems that
have been living off of the
american seniors investments by
overpaying in drug prices
and now they're going to have to bear
their fair share i got to tell you you
have
been what you've done and what you're
doing today you've done more than any
president in american history
to take on drug prices you have 10
[Applause]
you're taking on the drug companies
you're taking on the middlemen
you're taking on the european socialists
all for the forgotten men and women of
america who show up at the pharmacy
counter and for that i am so proud of
what you are doing today thank you mr
president
[Applause]
please
mr president thanks for your leadership
on this one uh we started the
legislative session in florida in 2019
uh our speaker of the house jose olivo's
here with me
he had a big healthcare agenda so we did
some phenomenal things like expand
telehealth repeal certificate of need
laws
but he really want to do something big
on prescription drugs i did too because
it's obviously an issue
but i told jose i said listen we got to
find a way where we will actually be
able to
accomplish something i don't want to
just throw a flare up there and then
virtue signal that we're doing something
about drugs then nothing works and so
there was a provision of law which
required the federal government's
approval
so we had a plan in florida we moved
forward i went to see you
and this law's been on the books for at
least almost 20 years so other
presidents have had the ability to pull
this lever
and uh and they didn't do it and i went
up
and asked you and not everyone was in
favor of you doing it you had a lot of
people saying don't do it
but you were laser focused on lowering
drug prices for people particularly
our seniors in the state of florida and
that was abundantly clear
and so when florida then moved forward
we knew we had your support we knew that
this day would eventually come
and i think the the fact that that we're
standing here today
obviously florida you know we did some
groundwork um but really
it's a result of presidential leadership
so the people of florida want to thank
you for for siding with us on this
um this this like i said this could have
been done for almost 20 years
and it hasn't been done so you're the
one that got it done so mr president
thank you very much
so we're going to sign four very
important documents i just want to thank
amy and congratulations amy to you and
that elevation is a big one and you're
going to do fantastically russell
congratulations just got confirmed and
we appreciate it fantastic job and pat
thank you very much for being here we
appreciate it thank you very much
okay let's go
oh
wow
thank you all
thank you very much
looks good
it's yours because that's what you have
to do right
implementation lowering prices for
patience by
eliminating kickbacks
[Applause]
[Applause]
this one will go into effect on august
25th
favorite nations
thank you very much
thank you all very much thank you sir
thank you
thank you all very much
good luck very much my pediatric
patients
you